[Musique]
dans notre salle au cinéma le grenier à
sel le vendredi 10 mai à 20h30
nous accueillons des courts métrages
locaux des courts métrages qui ont été
réalisés par des saint quentinois des
trappistes et un peu aux autres dans les
zones alentours il y a
une sélection de films qui a été fait
appel à films qui a été fait par
l'association jolie prof donc c'est un
partenariat entre la ville et rappelé
cinéma grenier à sel et l'association
jolie prod
les réalisateurs les équipes de films
seront présentes pour parler de leurs
films et vous présenter leur film
il y en a pour à peu près deux heures
donc ce sera ce vendredi 10 mai à 20h30
pour les autres courts métrages locaux
n'oubliez pas que le vendredi 24 mai à
18h30 il y aura les courts métrages
réalisés dans le cadre du partenariat
que nous avons avec le lycée de la
plaine au nord donc ce sont des lycéens
apprentis cinéastes qui viendront
présenter leurs films le vendredi 24 mai
à 18h30
à bientôt au cinéma le grenier à sel
[Musique]